hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to subnautica we've got
a lot of stuff to do but now we finally
have the tools to do it so I'm going to
take some of these for the road to munch
on while I'm swimming the long way back
good thing I got an extra battery so I
need to get over to the Aurora first I
got to make a pit stop at the Life pod
which I can just barely see in the
distance over there and then I need to
build the base by the Aurora so I am all
done here I'm pretty sure I scanned
everything that I need the only thing I
don't have is marble Mellon uh but I
think I'll be okay without the marble
milk dive dive dive dive dive ow my legs
and knees and intestines so I'm gonna
make my way over to the Life pod and
then to the Aurora to build my base so
anyway I'm gonna go do that now I'll be
back in a bit love you where did my life
pod drift back to the right place I
think it did good for you Bubba you know
where your home is oh god I have another
message I don't want to know I don't
want to know here we go 9 new biological
subjects designated mode switch hunting
analyzing sharing subject location with
other agents I don't know what any of
that means I have no idea what you're
talking about but I do know that I need
to get what I need to get and then I
need to get the Frick out of queue so
I'm gonna do is old old old already so I
only need one of these how can it be old
I literally just left the island all the
way I can still plant that and be able
to make what I need to make I'm gonna
take more titanium what do I need to
make a fabricator that's the most
important thing to be able to make
another fabricator when I get over there
I need to wire and kitten I need a
computer chip so I can make those here
and then do what I need to do I need
three silver oral or basically and then
I need to take that with me so I need
it'd take the titanium out of my goddamn
bag put it in the goddamn storage and
get the silver which is gonna be in the
UH it's gonna be in the the thingamabob
er you know down here in the death
forest
the forest of death silver teller
Delbert Delbert Delbert muskie alright
so now that we got enough silver ore
I even got a little extra so that I'd be
able to do everything that I need to do
once I get there and I need III would be
able to build more stuff and I've got
gold which I'm pretty sure is supposed
to be used for our solar panels I have
no idea but maybe maybe somehow I can
hook my base up to the Aurora and use
its radioactive core in some fashion to
be able to power my base I know that's
totally illogical and yeah thing is
totally back to exactly where it was I'm
just gonna dump all this cuz I need to
get table coral okay got that
flippity doo doo da flippidy so now I
should be able to make when I need to
make and what I need to do rotten god
damn it's getting more and more rotten
by the day I don't have any titanium but
frankly no I need titanium because
there's no time to hand me over there so
I need to be very strategic about what I
bring this should be enough to get me
started and then everything else I I
need to get later so I should have
everything I need to get where I need to
go that guy standing in my way I won't
let anything stand in my way
roppa do okay and well ruff squadala
weren't off squadala
wheel here we're not here we're still by
the way alright okay hello Aurora you're
looking lovely what a big honking ship
how did they shoot it down I mean again
who is they but how how did they shoot
it down what did they oh nice cool so
this is always gonna be marked off and
it's gonna be really annoying because if
I pick this one up the other one's gonna
be here so I'm gonna have like this
permanent glow let me just drop off some
of this titanium here so I can pick this
thing up cuz if the other thing oh good
the other ones not really there it's
kind of there I think it's still there
somewhere but thankfully it's not
forever there so I've got this stuff on
my lawn let me just push this off get
off my lawn
get off my lawn get off my lawn
this is a temporary base so it's not
gonna be 100% permanent here but at
least I'm going to start building
alright so you're going to be rut
Rick Rick here squad a law this is a
good enough place as any
ok so we got that we need the
multi-purpose room ah my titanium the
one that I put under oh if it's
unreachable under there I'm gonna be so
pissed where did it go where to go where
did it go no you can't do this to me you
can't do this to me I brought enough I
brought enough oh no oh no where did it
go oh damn it ah damn it okay there's
got to be there's got to be titanium
deposits around here somewhere there's
gotta be I spy with my little eye some
titanium Oh
all right so now I got everything that I
need I've had everything that I needed
no I forgot I don't have class [ __ ] I
can't build a goddamn hatch I'm a tit
monger I am so dumb I am is so
incredibly dumb I did not make any
goddamn glass aah do anger squats to
appease iishe when constructing larger
habitats that may be prudent to separate
work and leisure spaces in order to
maximize productivity treat this as your
home treat this space as your home but
remember that it is not get away from my
home you dick I have to go get some
glass fricker Dekker all right I'll be
back but I don't have any more goddamn
power oh hello well that's weird there's
that locker with the picture of the lady
here same locker that we've seen in a
lot of places but there's nothing down
here
luggage bag luggage bag luggage bag I've
never ever seen a luggage bag before Oh
God ten seconds oh [ __ ] no oh come on
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ] you
where am I
where the heck am i god damn it ha [ __ ]
I still got the luggage bag that's okay
okay so I guess that was actually just a
shortcut to get me back to the base
sooner but okay whatever
I found a luggage bag I have no idea
what the luggage bag is hang on let's
see about this luggage bag what what
what what what
really oh it oh it's a storage container
I can place in in in might in my foot
place oh okay that's weird okay I'm
gonna make glass I'm gonna make it a lot
of glass alright so anyway I'm headed
back to the other base I got glassed to
make a hatch to be able to get in there
I've got enough to make a fabricator
there but I also need power that is
another thing that I need so I won't be
able to fabricate anything until I make
solar panels which need quartz and
titanium but that's fine because I don't
need to fabricate anything so I can make
those and then fabricate what I need so
I should have absolutely everything I
need - the quartz which I'm gonna grab
on the way there so all that said and
done I am in relatively good shape and
I'm not gonna [ __ ] and moan about
anything anymore
ever okay hatch Oh
maybe I shouldn't put it here I'll fix
it later if I do all right
hon I'm home
oxygen production it works so I just
need to make one I need to get one more
quartz which is right here oddly enough
I need to get this one quartz and then I
need to I'll make a solar panel and then
I should be good to go for pretty much
anything that I need in terms of power
production because I'm pretty close to
the surface which means that I'm gonna
get a lot of Sun so it should be pretty
efficient why can I not make there we go
ah come on okay so I need one more
titanium before I do that it's not of a
biscuit come on give me some goddamn
titanium where's all the limestone there
we go there we go that's all I needed to
with this I can now salvage the bigger
pieces of metal that I got and create a
storage container I don't have the
materials to do that but you know I got
the duffel bag that's why I brought the
luggage bag so I can store stuff perfect
excellent
and it'll make it a little homey we'll
touch a home little touch of humanity in
my place which is good cuz I don't have
any other human companions
I am literally all alone here haha
alright and they fixed up the solar
panel to look a little better which is
kind of nice
I put it right there right on the
entrance I'll be good
that's why I can stack them up a little
better oh yay okay we got it
ha Bisky alright that's good okay so now
we just need to make be fabric [ __ ]
[ __ ] titanium god dammit god dammit
it's gonna be nighttime by the time I
get all this [ __ ] done and then I'm not
gonna be able to get any power [ __ ] I
just need one more titanium one one more
come on are you kidding me have I ever
looked I'm really skin and really hard
into this frickin chasm can't see any
more goddamn limestone outcropping
it's gotta be one more there's got to be
just one sweet delicious more piece of
gosh-darn titanium ah try to blend in I
see you yes yes do I have what I need I
have one wait no I have one I've stepped
one what excuse me what the Frick I
thought I had another one but I guess
I'm mistaken god damn it
maybe if I go somewhere else I can find
some limestone [ __ ] because
apparently it's not here
goddamn it really it's gonna be night by
the time I find this son of a [ __ ] I
could have I could have swam all the way
back to my own life pod grab the rest of
my [ __ ] titanium cuz I don't know
why I decided that I needed to be sparse
at that point in time but apparently I'm
a bargaining man apparently I'm an idiot
that's why I'm not seeing anything yep
and here comes the night excellent
no titanium perfect exactly what I
wanted exactly what please be titanium
[ __ ] you come on please please baby [ __ ]
you [ __ ] you [ __ ] you and [ __ ] all of
you not you guys [ __ ] all these
limestone's I see one more over there
I'm gonna get it
Tennyson's I get some goddamn air
everyone's angry for me I get it I
understand and I appreciate the empathy
this better have frickin titanium in it
this better it's bitter better batter
bitter I gotta get rid of my goddamn
copper kipper swabue ski yes
finally finally hi can't believe how
hard that was dick joke ah okay but we
got what we needed now I can make a
fabricator and then finally I can just
pick up the scrap pieces turn them into
titanium this shouldn't have taken so
long I don't know
it did but it did and I will I will
survive I Will Survive I will persevere
I will do whatever it takes to survive
in the dark depths of the [ __ ] Oh
Shan ok alright ok here we go Schoop yes
my woop yes scuba do you know a little
off from where I had it but oh boo ski
I've got it I've got it
aerogel what the [ __ ] is that what ok
anyway we don't need to worry about that
because I need to go grandma on those
titanium scrap pieces which should be
which was right in my lawn but someone
took it there we go that's what I needed
right there San char get away I don't
want you here I got that that's all I
need for that
I think abut this and here make it into
titanium four pieces of titanium how
hard was that
why'd that have to be so hard ok so we
got that
hey big boo-boo would be big oh no wait
I wanted to put the duffel bag down for
some reason no no no no no no no I need
food but I need to put the duffel bag
into slot one and put it right
right right right right right right
there oh look at that
that doesn't do anything that's a
decoration piece ah that's not actual
storage Hey [ __ ] [ __ ] alright
Aereo let me just make a locker no I
need to make a wall locker because I
need it
oh that's right I need to put the names
yes okay so I'm gonna do that I'm gonna
gonna put him up a bit higher than I had
him before I like him up a bit higher
and a bouzouki okay there we go
ah the lockers are back yeah okay anyway
so I need to put this stuff away
that is super run but the copper away
but the lead away salt glass that uh
this um where did I get so much glass
did I make a like last I need to make
all that glass flare we got the
rebreather I'm gonna keep on me Ron land
fruit can go in there let's see if we
can make a grow bed we don't have the
titanium at the moment but that's
because I put it away maybe yes I did
okay so I'm gonna try to make an
interior Grob
Edie put it Ride Schubert as Schubert of
Shubin to Shubin shoe buddy and can I
put okay can I put the rotten thing in
there and will it grow is the question
can I put the rocket yay
is it gonna grow ah yeah there is yes we
got food growing yay oh this is a
wonderful day oh it's a wonderful day
and when that goes it's gonna be so nice
because it's gonna grow full and big big
and full it's gonna grow so nice and
we're gonna be able to eat our own food
but right now I actually don't have any
food and we're running low on power cuz
it's currently nighttime oh man that was
a slog that was an adventure that was a
waste of time but that's okay because
that's all part of the experience so
before I end this episode here I am
going to try to get a bead whoo
try to get a lock on material supplies
everything I need and also source some
food so if any of you slowpokes want to
be eaten by me yep apparently they do so
I got some slowpokes here hover fish
peeper and all that jazz but that's good
because we didn't just eat those up yum
yum yum and then I'm pretty close to the
Aurora I'm pretty close to where I need
to go what what I need for the Aurora
what I have been told is the repulsion
cannon and the propulsion cannon but the
interesting thing is the schematics for
those are actually near the outside
entrance of the Aurora so I need that to
be able to get in the Aurora and then
move [ __ ] around to get what I need to
get and I'm willing to bet that the
exosuit is in there somewhere I don't
know for certain but I'm guessing so
with all that said and done I just need
a little more materials and then we will
be able to
on okay we've got materials I'm gonna
make one more of these bad boys
stack them real nice and tight like that
ah
boink I'm gonna make a spotlight just so
that I can know where the Frick my door
is I'm gonna put this here there okay ah
boo ski okay I know that's gonna consume
power but it's gonna be useful for me
finding this place in the darkness and
I've got two solar panels anyway so it
should be okay and it consumes a lot of
power though I'll deconstruct it if it's
necessary so I've got grow bed a base
I've got a fabricator I've got Locker
I've got a duffle bag I'm doing pretty
good for myself and next up on the list
is the Aurora itself which I'm going to
tackle very soon but now officially I
have the lockers back which means that I
will be able to put you guys's names on
there so if you've got any tips and
tricks that you want me to do in the
next episode that might help me along
let me know down in the comments below I
have been reading and I will continue to
be reading so let me know and I may just
put your name on the locker so thank you
everybody so much for watching and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye bye